Hi everyone, I'm Gareth. I love hacking and finding creative ways to solve problems and
explore systems. When I'm not hacking, I'm building tools to hack faster and smarter.
One of my favourite projects is Hackverter, a Burpsuite extension I created to handle
all kinds of conversions and make life easier for hackers like me.
Recently, I got really excited to hear that we're adding AI functionality to the Montoya API in Burp.
It's a game changer that makes adding AI features to BAPS easier than ever. Let me show you some of
the new features I added to Hackverter. Before we start using these enhancements, we first need to
configure Burp and Hackverter to enable the AI features. So head over to the extensions tab.
And check the use AI checkbox. Then go to the Hackverter menu.
And click settings. Then check all the AI features and enable them.
You also want to allow code execution tags in order to do some of the demos in the video.
And hit update. Great, we're all set. So now we'll demo some of the new AI features.
For the first demo, I'm going to show you how to create AI custom tags.
Hackverter supports different programming languages such as Python and JavaScript.
But now you can use AI prompts to perform conversions.
Imagine you have an MD5 hash that you want to crack.
And because the AI has traversed the whole web, it knows the plain text of many MD5 hashes.
So this is an MD5 hash of let me in.
So let's use AI custom tags to crack it.
First, go to the Hackverter menu bar and click create custom tag.
Then we've got the custom tag window.
In the custom tag window, I'm going to type a name crack MD5 as the tag name.
Then I'm going to enter a prompt.
Crack this MD5 hash.
Cool.
So click create tag.
And now this tag is available in the custom section.
And here you can see crack MD5.
So let's click that.
And then this sends the information off to the AI.
The AI uses the prompt and cracks the hash.
Dead easy.
In this second demo, I'm going to show you how easy it is to create custom tags even without programming knowledge.
Let's open the create new custom tag window again.
Now enter reverse me as the tag name.
Reverse me.
And select JavaScript as the language.
In the code box, let's enter your prompt.
So in this case, reverse this text.
And click use AI to generate code.
Now Hackverter will ask you for some input.
So let's give it some input.
A, B, C.
And the expected output is C, B, A.
Great.
Press OK.
And it's created a custom tag for you automatically just from your inputs.
The advantage over this than using an AI tag is that once the code is created, you don't use any more tokens.
So it's really handy.
So let's finish off and create that tag.
In this demo, I'm going to show you how the AI automatically created a description of the custom tag we created.
First, let's navigate to the custom tag we previously created by clicking the Hackverter menu.
And click list custom tags.
And select the reverse me tag that we created.
And click edit.
As you can see, the AI has automatically created a text description of what the code does.
This is useful if you're not familiar with the programming language in question.
For the final demo, I'm going to show you an experimental feature that will automatically create custom tags from repeater requests.
So let's go to the repeater tab.
And then click on the extensions tab.
So let's just check to see if it works.
So click test tag.
Enter test as the input.
And as you can see, it's created a hex escape string.
Burp has always provided unparalleled extensibility.
Enabling you to customize the world's most powerful web app testing toolkit.
To fit your workflow and handle specialized technologies like JWT.
With the largest community of extension developers.
And the BAP store.
Innovation has always been at the heart of Burp.
Now we're taking things a step further.
With new enhancements to the Montoya API.
We're empowering pen testers and bug bounty hunters.
To seamlessly integrate AI powered functionality into their extensions.
As you've seen.
I've been experimenting with this.
Upgrading the popular Hackverter extension.
To include AI capabilities.
Now it's your turn.
If you're an extension developer.
We challenge you to take your creations to the next level.
By harnessing the power of AI.
The possibilities are endless.
Let's see what you can build.